what do you think of the World Cup
situation have you been watching it
yeah I watched England get their ass
kicked yesterday terrible game bro you
know what
the English in me comes out around
football I don't because the English
cares so much and we never win ever
anything it's [ __ ] it's so annoying
but um and especially to the French
always had to beat the [ __ ] out of Luke
he's part French trying to beat his ass
but um yeah the the World Cup's been
interesting it's been very funny to
watch the Western World try and complain
at Qatar like we have some degree of
moral High Ground because qataris don't
want to
pollute their culture by promoting LGBT
garbage to kids you know they we we in
the west think that we are the only
moral people on Earth and if another
culture says that you shouldn't be
promoting LGBT ideals to children on
television and that football has nothing
to do with gay sex so just let it be
football that we're gonna somehow
Pretend We're morally obliged to attack
their their institutions and their
religious beliefs that's absolutely not
only insane the West has no moral High
Ground whatsoever the things we do in
the west are disgusting
some under the guise of lbgt whether
it's chopping kids dicks off or just
some other things in general are
discussing like all the wars we start
and the innocent people we kill to sit
here and pretend that we as a western
conglomerate are the only moral people
on earth is truly asinine and I respect
the qataris for standing up what they
believe in and saying no we don't care I
completely respect that and obviously
they're doing that under a religious
belief and I don't see why religious
beliefs should be thrown out the window
temporarily for sports anyway so I
completely respect what Qatar is doing
with the World Cup I think we've done a
fantastic job with it and I think the
West can get the [ __ ] over it why do we
have to mix this [ __ ] I'm asking why
as a rhetorical question because I
already know the answer why do we have
to mix all these [ __ ] agendas with
everything why does football have
anything to do with the agenda of lgbtq
acceptance and they're completely
unrelated what they're trying to do is
to take anything which is remotely
popular and slap this garbage on top of
it so you can't be a normal football fan
and now without also supporting the
garbage they want you to support the
majority of football fans don't give a
[ __ ] about this [ __ ] so that is mix the
two together it's like putting the
vitamins into Coca-Cola so you have to
[ __ ]
the medicine the poison and it's
[ __ ] and they're doing it on purpose
because like we said earlier they're
trying to drag men down they're trying
to do everything they can to remove the
idea of traditionally masculine man
because he's prepared to defend an ideal
they don't want any ideals defended they
want us to sit there bend over and take
anything we're [ __ ] given so they
take anything which is remotely
masculine that's left like football
where groups of men play play football
and watch football and traditionally a
masculine Enterprise and they kick this
garbage and they slap it on top it's
[ __ ] insane I'm glad Qatar told them
to get [ __ ]
yeah it's you know it's a clown world
man I've I've said for years now though
you know the pussification of the West
is well on its way to uh and it's going
to continue
um I don't see it uh you know lightening
up they're now trying to impose these
beliefs in countries where they don't
accept them